well they're probably confused because
they've not read it but the reality is
that I have been spending time in this
campaign listening to American families
listening to experts listening to
healthcare providers and what I came
away with is a very clear understanding
that I needed to create a plan that was
responsive to the needs of the American
people responsive to their needs
understanding that insurance companies
have been jacking up the prices are far
too long that American families have to
be held down by deductibles and co-pays
and and and and premiums that can cause
them bankruptcy I listened to the
American families who said four years is
just not enough to transition into this
new plan so I devised a plan where it's
gonna be ten years of a transition I
listened to American families who said I
want an option that will be under your
Medicare system that allows a private
plan so I designed a plan where yes
responsive to the needs of American
families there will be a public plan
under my plan for Medicare and a private
plan under my plan for Medicare because
the bottom line is this we must agree
that access to health care must be a
right and not just a privilege of those
who can afford it and in America today
far too many people in fact 30 million
people are going without access to
health care Thank You senator Harris
Vice President Biden your response well
my response is that the Senators had
several plans so far and any time
someone tells you're going to get
something good in ten years you should
wonder why it takes ten years if you
notice there's no talk about the fact
that the plan in ten years will cost
three trillion dollars if you will lose
your employer based insurance and in
fact you know this is a single most
important issue facing the public and to
be very blunt and to be very
straightforward you can't be President
Trump with double-talk on this plan your
response center absolutely unfortunately
Vice President Biden you're just simply
inaccurate in what you're describing the
reality is that our plan will bring
health care to all Americans under a
medicare-for-all system our plan will
allow people to start signing up on the
first day babies will be born into our
plan and
now four million babies almost are born
every day in America or every year in
America under our plan we will ensure
that everyone has access to health care
your plan by contrast leaves out almost
10 million Americans so I think that you
should really think about what you're
saying but be reflective and understand
that the people of America want access
to health care and do not want cost to
be their barrier to getting it senator
Harris thank you Vice President Biden
your response the plan no matter how you
cut it cost three trillion dollars when
it is in fact employed number one ten
years from now after two terms of the
senator being president after her time
secondly it will require middle-class
taxes to go up not down thirdly it will
eliminate employer-based insurance and
fourthly what happens in the meantime
I'd like to respond first of all the
cost of doing nothing is far too
expensive second we are now paying three
bill a trillion dollars a year for
health care in America over the next 10
years is probably going to be six
trillion dollars we must act my plan is
about immediately allowing people to
sign up and get into coverage right now
in America we have seniors who every day
millions of seniors are going into the
Medicare system and they are getting
full coverage and the kind of coverage
they need all people should have access
to health care and caution